this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill
last month MIT revealed their ion
propelled plane the product of seven
years of development and the first of
its kind a plane capable of sustained
powered flight with no moving parts in
its propulsion system just as the Wright
brothers announced to the world that
powered flight was possible
this flight lays down a milestone for
ion drive technology that could pave the
way to future investment and development
it has the potential to drastically
improve propulsion technology having no
moving parts is a benefit that cannot be
understated parts can be made lighter as
they no longer need to survive the
stress of movement reduce stress means
reduce maintenance and costs but perhaps
the most immediate benefit we can garner
from this technology is reduced noise
with no noisy combustion or rotating
aerodynamic surfaces stirring up the air
these planes are like gliding else
a characteristic military contractors
will be eager to take advantage of but
with current limitations this may take
some time to come to market let's
investigate how this new technology
works and where it needs to improve in
order to compete with current technology
this technology has been in development
for decades now with manney spacecraft
already using variations on the idea to
achieve highly efficient thrust systems
these engines work on a similar
principle to the iron propulsion of the
MIT plane albeit in a very different
environment that lends itself to the
technology take the end star ion drive
aboard the now retired Dawn spacecraft
this spacecraft used xenon as a
propellant because it has a high atomic
mass allowing it to provide more kick
per atom while being a nurse and having
a high storage density lending itself to
long-term storage on a spacecraft the
engine releases both xenon atoms and
high-energy electrons into the
ionization chamber where they collide to
produce a positive xenon atom and more
electrons these electrons are then
collected by the positively charged
chamber walls while the positive xenon
atoms migrate towards the chamber exit
which contains two grids a positive grid
called a screen grid and a negative grid
called the accelerator grid
the high electrical potential between
these grids causes the positive ions to
accelerate and shoot out of the engine
at speeds of up to a hundred and
forty-five thousand kilometers per hour
at that speed even the tiny xenon atoms
can provide a decent bit of thrust but
even still this engine provides a
maximum of 92 million newtons of force
about the same force a piece of paper
will exert while resting on your hand
but in the vacuum of space there is no
air to slap away the precious energy we
provide with no drag or friction to
remove energy we gradually build our
kinetic energy and gain speed the Dawn
spacecraft weighed about 1220 kilograms
at launch with a dry mass of 750
kilograms
after the propellant had been expended
so let's say it has an average weight
between the two of 1,000 kilograms
rearranging the force equals mass by
acceleration equation we can calculate
the acceleration this engine can provide
at zero point zero zero zero zero 92
meters per second squared
a tiny acceleration but multiplied by a
week and our spacecraft is flying at 55
point six meters per second multiplied
by a year and it's flying at 2898 meters
per second that's 8.5 Mach the latest
generation ion drives dubbed the next
engine can produce three times the
forests and have been tested
continuously without stopping for six
years straight here on earth
that's enough force to accelerate that
1,000 kilograms to 44,000 651 meters per
second 130 times the speed of sound this
is an incredible technology that will
revolutionize how we explore space in
the near future but here on earth it has
a completely different set of challenges
here on earth
planes pose a completely different
challenge air will continuously SAP away
any energy we input into our vehicle
through drag and so we need to create an
ion drive that can provide more energy
than air can remove while traveling fast
enough to achieve flight not an easy
task
and the fact MIT have managed it is
mind-blowing
let's see how they did it they first
needed to optimize their plane design
for the application reducing waste to
minimize the energy required to maintain
height and
minimizing drag to reduce any energy
losses to the air they did this using
something called geometric programming
optimization which allows designers to
specify constraints and design criteria
to a program which will then find the
optimal design after running multiple
computer simulations they settled on a
plane with a 5 meter wingspan and a
weight of 2.5 6 kilograms it would
require a flight speed of 4.8 m/s with a
thrust of 3.2 Newton's 3.2 Newton's is
vastly more than anything achieved by
the answer or next engines but they
don't work in entirely the same way ion
drives for space need to carry atoms to
be bombarded with in Earth's atmosphere
there is no shortage of atoms to ionize
and accelerate and this helps contract
some of the negatives of the drag they
also induce the plane's propulsion comes
from an array of ion drives carried
below the wing the positive anode was a
thin steel wire which helped minimize
the drag in induced while the cathodes
were foam aerofoils covered in thin
aluminium these being light and capable
of producing lift to offset their weight
in this case nitrogen is ionized and
attracted across the electric field
induced by the 20,000 volts of electric
potential between them the nitrogen ions
collide with neutral air molecules along
the way to provide additional thrust
creating something called ionic wind
getting that 20,000 volts of alternating
current is really the most difficult
part and the team had to design their
own lightweight high-power voltage
converter to step up the 200 volts of
direct current drawn from the lithium
polymer batteries this energy storage
conundrum as explained in my electric
planes video is the biggest challenge
facing any technology like this so how
does this compare to conventional
propulsion methods regarding thrust to
power ratios a typical jet engine
achieves a thrust to power ratio of 3
Newton's per kilowatt while helicopter
rotors achieve a power to thrust ratio
of about 50 Newton's per kilowatt this
ion propelled plane is estimated to have
achieved a thrust the power ratio 6.25
Newton's per kilowatt so if we could
find a way of powering these devices
that didn't require heavy batteries
could these iron propulsion engines
used scaling these propulsion methods is
not easy and individual electrode pairs
have their limit in the current they can
pass between them via ion transport due
to limits in voltage and choked flow
within the electric field just as air
can become choked within a constricted
pipe this affects something called the
thrust density which is the area over
which the thrust is applied
jet engines have a very high thrust
density at over 10,000 Newton's per
meter squared so we can produce a great
amount of force with relatively low area
now this plane achieved that thrust
density of 3 Newtons per meter squared
so it is generating very little force
over a very large area we can just about
manage to provide enough force with for
racks and 2 rows of these electrodes
hanging far below the wing for a plane
this light and slow the issue here is
the same issue that prevents batteries
from being a viable solution for planes
power requirements do not scale
literally with the mass of the plane
they increase with the square of the
mass while the power requirements to
overcome drag increase with the cube of
the velocity so our ion propulsion power
will need to scale with it but we cannot
simply hang racks and racks of these
electrodes beneath our plane they along
with the structures required to support
them would cause fire too much drag and
in turn flight surfaces would need to
scale to counteract the pitching moment
this would cause causing even more drag
this technology is still in its infancy
and there are engineers far more
intelligent than I working to figure out
ways to apply it but just think that 114
years ago the Wright Flyer managed to
fly just 35 metres in its 11 second
first flight this ion propelled plane
managed 55 metres in 12 seconds and who
knows where we will be in 100 years time
we as a species are continually growing
and learning how to apply these
principles it's a fundamental part of
the human experience
to continuously develop your skill set
just as I have been developing my Segway
skills by watching this course by
Wendover productions about how to make
an educational video essay you can learn
about any number of topics on Skillshare
like app development or animation new
years is the perfect time to set some
goals and learn a valuable life skill
these days you can teach yourself
pretty much any skill online and
Skillshare is a fantastic place to do it
with professional and understandable
classes that follow a clear learning
curve you can dive in and start learning
how to do the work you love a premium
membership begins around $10 a month for
unlimited access to all courses but the
first 1,000 people to sign up with this
link will get their first two months for
free as usual thanks for watching and
thank you to all my patreon supporters
if you would like to see more from me
the links to my Twitter Facebook discord
server subreddit and Instagram pages are
below
[Music]